il est tout juste 8 heures lorsque lee
chloé et jules font irruption dans la
cour de récré de quoi rendre chèvre la
maîtresse ces dizaines d'animaux ont
décidé de se regrouper au pied de
l'école de moutier en bresse ce matin le
but de cette mobilisation organisée par
les parents d'élèves protester contre la
suppression d'une des quatre classes du
secteur prévue pour la rentrée 2010 9
avec 24 élèves au minimum par classe
contre 19 actuellement
on arrive à des effectifs très haut il
va y avoir des niveaux triple c'est à
dire trois niveaux dans la même classe
cp ce1 ce2 sachant qu'un élève de cp
doit savoir lire à la fin de l'année et
que quand on a des ce1 et des cieux et
deux en même temps
eh ben c'est vraiment pas simple à sept
kilomètres de là à torpes la stratégie
est la même
l'inquiétude aussi en tout 74 élèves de
la petite section de maternelle au cm2
sont concernés par cette mesure
sa réponse est de dire que les tout
petits section ils dorment tout l'après
midi mais c'est faux ça c'est un leurre
il fait même pas les hôpitaux
mais ferme des postes à l'intérieur il
est bas les écoles c'est la même chose
en ferme pas les écoles on ferme les
classes voilà la difficulté
donc on leur malgré la promesse du chef
de l'état deux héros fermetures d'écoles
d'ici 2024
les parents craignent à terme la
fermeture d'un des trois établissements
du regroupement pédagogique
intercommunal
si les maires du rpi prennent la
décision de réorganiser de fermer une
école il ya aucune difficulté et nous
les accompagnerons pour le faire s'il
décide de conserver leur école si la
scolarisation des moins de trois ans et
préserver cette année et qui a le nombre
d'élèves parce qu'il nous faut quand
même quelques élèves il y en a sept donc
ça serait plutôt favorable on ré ouvrira
le post l'année prochaine voilà on a une
année de transition
d'ici là le troupeau d'enfants reprendra
gentiment le chemin de l'école
[Musique]